how do we balance the threat of the
kovat 19 pandemic and the need to get on
with our lives and get back to work
is it time to liberate the US economy
from government lock downs that was the
question on the table during the online
Soho forum debate held on Tuesday April
21st David Henderson an economist and
research fellow with the Hoover
Institution at Stanford University
argued for an immediate opening of the
American economy Justin Wolfers a
professor of economics and public policy
at the University of Michigan argued
against the resolution here's David
Henderson versus Justin Wolfers in an
online debate hosted by Soho forum
director Jean Epstein defending the
resolution which is the US economy
should be liberated from the
government's lockdowns right away a
Hoover Institution Fellow David R
Henderson
opposing the resolution University of
Michigan economics professor Justin
Wolfers now the affirmative goes first
the negative is the is there going to be
the cleanup hitter so David I want your
up in a moment Jane please close the
voting David take it away oh and also I
should mention that a five that when you
have five minutes to go I'm gonna
interrupt you briefly and tell you give
you the five minute warning and I'll
also give you the one-minute morning
again David take it away
hope it didn't start because now it
starts well first of all I want to thank
everyone for showing up
thank reason for doing this thank Jean
for doing this and Justin we have a very
pleasant talk a few minutes ago and I
want to just say I think there's one
lockdown that Justin and I are both
against he's from Australia I'm from
Canada and I'm guessing that he like me
thinks Trump should not be stopping
immigration so I'm proposing that the
economy be liberated from governments
lockdowns today the lock downs have
caused
destruction the odds are extremely high
they're basically 99.9% that the
unemployment rate today if measured
correctly would be over 15% and maybe
higher economists now estimate that on
an annual basis quarterly GDP will be at
least 30% lower and during the current
spring quarter that's amazing and so
let's put that in perspective u.s. GDP
last year was twenty one point four
trillion even with just zero growth
therefore we would have had five point
three five trillion GDP in this quarter
a 30% drop of that from that is one
point six trillion if only half of that
drug was due to the lockdown and I think
probably more than half was that's 800
billion let's put that in perspective
the price of a know you know a basic
Ford f-150 truck is $30,000 so the cost
to our economy if you think in terms of
trucks is 300,000 Ford f-150s per day
those aren't the only losses there's a
loss in health also a new story in
yesterday's print edition of The Wall
Street Journal noted that state
governments have ordered medical
providers and patients to delay
so-called non-essential for procedures
we're not just talking plastic surgery
here it includes hip and knee
replacements mastectomies and preventive
screenings interestingly this is
resulted in furloughs of healthcare
workers and might result in fact in
bankruptcies of some hospitals which is
kind of ironic those are some of the
economic and health losses there's also
a huge loss in our economic freedom on
the freedom front Justin Wolfers and I
have a huge advantage over most people
we are what sometimes are called
academics scribblers we make our living
by writing speaking
teaching dealing with colleagues this
debate and we can do all of that from
home so there are certain losses to our
lifestyle it does get old being at home
but those are really minor compared to
what compared to waiters people in
restaurants factory workers who are
losing their livelihood and retail who
are losing their livelihoods sometimes a
hundred percent of their livelihoods
classical liberals and libertarians and
I'm in that category have often been
charged with not caring about the
working class well that tribes never
stood up to scrutiny but it's especially
not applicable now we who defend the
right of people to make a living are the
strongest allies of the working class
and why did these lockdowns happen
well started with Donald Trump declaring
a national emergency and then over 80%
of state governments imposing lock downs
was this because government officials at
various levels knew what would happen
had good information about how bad this
would be no indeed early on some of
those same government officials really
minimized it at a January 17th press
conference dr. Nancy Missoni a of the
Centers for Disease Control stated quote
based on the information the CDC has
today we believe the current risk from
this virus to the general public is low
for a family sitting around the dinner
table tonight tonight this is not
something that they generally need to
worry about
similarly politicians were badly and for
uninformed when it mattered
New York's Mayor Bill DeBlasio did no
one any favors on March 4 fifth when he
wrote in New York subway and said quote
I'm here on the subway to say to people
nothing to fear go about your lives and
we will tell you if you have to change
your habits but that's not now and on
March 6
New York's Metropolitan Transit
Authority which operates the subways
erred badly when it for bad
employees for wearing masks the fact is
that no one knew how bad this would be
and government officials went from
saying it was minor to saying it could
take more than two million US lives they
seem to have throttled back on that last
estimate all but one major government
official is not throttled back yesterday
Eric Garcetti the mayor of Los Angeles
in criticizing protesters against the
lockdown said quote the worst thing
would be to lift the floodgates and
watch all of your friends and neighbors
die all of your friends and neighbors
die let's compare the kovat 19 to the
flu not because of the same but because
it gives us a baseline according to the
CDC the worst flu season we had in
decades was just two years ago was 61
thousand deaths yet we had no lockdowns
then that's not because we had a great
vaccine the flu vaccine was 34%
effective against flu a influenza A and
56% effective against influenza B how
bad would deaths have to be for it to be
reasonable for government to impose the
extreme measures they've imposed I
honestly don't know but if we had three
times that number say a hundred and
eighty three thousand deaths I don't
think it would be justified
interestingly Anthony Fauci in his
latest estimate a week or two ago said
he expects about 60,000 Kovan 19 deaths
by the end of August putting it in the
same ballpark as our worst flu season of
course some of that reduction is due to
the lockdown but some and possibly a
large part of it is due to our private
voluntary activity and that brings me to
a key distinction we need to make which
is the distinction between social
distancing and lockdowns people
sometimes equate them they're very
different they're related but they're
very different many of us were social
distancing well before the lockdowns
look at the NBA they canceled or they
delayed their season and now
it's likely to be canceled be at least a
week maybe a week and a half before
Morse lockdowns
NCAA followed quickly and just and just
decided not to have March Madness and
basketball the NHL from which I'm from
Canada so that's a very very fond of
that basically ended the hockey season
that was all before these lock downs
that's important for two reasons first
it shows people were taking this very
seriously second it shows that the
flattening of the covin curve that has
clearly taken place cannot all be
attributed to the lock downs economist
Tyler Cowen argues that Utah Jazz
basketball player Rudy Gobert by getting
in public eye publicizing covered 19
indirectly saved thousands of lives
Tyler doesn't have good evidence for
that but it's plausible the good news is
that if we end the lock downs people who
want to show up shelter-in-place will be
free to do so as they've always been
no one is making them come out or at
least no one should make them come out
take the out early among whom or my wife
and I we are at the greatest risk of the
us deaths that CDC attributed to Kovac
19 up until yesterday 78% were of people
aged 65 and more the vast majority of
people in that age range are not working
outside the home so it's relatively easy
easier for us to stay in our homes and
not get the disease be careful though in
thinking the sheltering in place is the
right idea people in nursing homes are
sheltered shelter in place almost by
definition but in some countries
including my native Canada over half the
kovat 19 deaths are linked to care homes
which are is another word for nursing
homes that's according to the LSC London
School of Economics study also I want to
point out that in a in a market in a
labor market there are what's called
compensating differentials people who
take risks
pay for those risks and in fact that's
what's behind many economist estimates
today of what's called the value of a
statistical life and so they get paid to
take risks that gives employers an
incentive to care about safety because
they can cut the wage bill from by doing
so and I just want to point out an
example from youth last weekend's Wall
Street Journal quote Smithfield Tyson
Cargill Cargill jbs and other meat
companies over that past month have
offered bonus pay to processing plant
employees and in some cases are
installing barriers between meat cutting
stations on processing lines is that
perfect no because the employees just
think about their own safety but the
point is it's it's it's a substantial
improvement from the case if we didn't
have that will the market outcome be
perfect of course not but let's compare
the imperfect market outcome with the
imperfect government outcome to show
that the state government's improve the
situation with their lockdowns we would
have to be able to show that the
additional safety produced was quite
large relative to costs we know the
costs were huge what we don't know is
the additional benefits we can't just
assume that the flattening of the curve
is due to the lock downs I looked at
Justin's one of Justin's sold syllabi
online and one thing that really
impressed me was in one of his courses
this public policy course he emphasizes
marginal analysis and he's right to do
so what we would need to know is the
marginal desk prevented from a lock down
over and above the desk the social
distancing was creating created and if
you look at most of the studies that say
hey this is a good idea by economists
they're coming up with them very quickly
they do two things they assume a huge
number of deaths without the lock downs
and they fail to separate between the
lock downs and the social distancing
lock downs are an instance of central
planning governors with apparently
little information and little thought
decided which businesses were essential
and which ones were not it
chicken for example governor Whitmer's
saw the sale of lottery tickets as
essential but her order does not allow
people to buy paint go out in their
motorboat go to their cottages or hire
someone to take care of their lawn her
priorities seemed to reflect those of a
narrowly focused prosecutor which she
actually was rather than of someone who
cares a lot about Michigan citizens and
in my own state of California governor
Newsom imposed the same lockdown on all
the rural counties that's imposed on San
Francisco and Los Angeles this is
despite the fact that 37 of the 58
California counties have had three or
fewer deaths so far 21 counties have had
zero deaths and five counties have had
zero cases Newsom has used a
sledgehammer rather than a scalpel
but that's what governments do and we're
talking about a lockdown we have to look
at what governments actually do what not
what someone's favorite version of
lockdown would be and why was that free
demanded for tens of millions of people
because the proponents argued
ventilators and other key medical
resources were in short supply and we
needed to flatten the curve that is make
sure that the number of Kovan 19 cases
plus the number of emergency cases of
other types wouldn't shut went overwhelm
huge parts of production now there's a
standard idea in both economics and in
operations analysis which is when you
have a bottleneck like that you focus on
the bottleneck you don't say let's shut
down a huge mile of them out of the rest
of the economy so to reduce demand for
the bottleneck you focus on the
bottleneck that takes time of course and
Donald Trump's invocation of the defense
production Act to make GM produce more
of what they already said they wanted to
produce probably slow thing to things
down the biggest mistakes in this whole
episode have been due to central
planning early on the CDC rather than
letting coronavirus test kits from the
World Health Organization do the job
insisted on producing their own and then
screwed up produced a defective product
that lost us about a month which it with
a fast-moving disease is a huge amount
of time then as the New York Times
reported in a first-rate investigative
report the FDA prevented dr. Helen Shu
in Washington state from using samples
for another reason to test for the virus
when she went ahead anyway
despite the FDA's prohibition dr. Chiu
found Koba 19 present and a young man
who had not traveled abroad did the FDA
admit its error you joke they did what
governments do they said to her cease
and desist and of course the FDA has
slowed down both tests for the virus and
for approval and approvals of drugs that
might help most of that other than the
FDA slowing down drugs is a sunk cost
here we are the curve was flattened even
New York City which is in the worst
shape seems to have excess capacity so
if the purpose of such an extreme
shutdown was to flatten the curve let's
declare victory and move on so how
should we end the lockdown a good
principle is that no one should be
forced to be in a risky situation that
he doesn't want to be in does ending a
lockdown involved open schools again yes
some parents and their children may be
afraid and they but they should be
allowed to act on that fear that means
compulsory schooling should end the
parents who keep their age 18 children
under out of school should not be
charged with a crime as they sometimes
are now let the parents choose whether
to put their kids and themselves
indirectly at risk I think ending
compulsion is a long long run excellent
idea many people listening to this might
disagree with me I think it's a great
short run deregulation will there be
Kovan 19 deaths if the lockdowns are in
it immediately absolutely will there be
more deaths than if the lockdowns were
not in it immediately probably but that
won't be enough to pronounce that ending
lockdowns was a bad idea the reason is
there are trade offs between guests and
other parts of economic well-being and
especially given how badly state
governments in the federal government
have handled a situation we should be
free to act on our own information and
make our own trade-offs do we have
perfect information no one does
partly because of my age I'm 69 I talked
to a number of friends in the seventy
five to seventy five 65 to 75 age range
a few of them are quite afraid of the
virus they've told me that even if the
lockdown ends they're gonna be careful
so it's perfect timing they're gonna be
careful about going out and that's how
it should be Scott Sumner one of my co
bloggers at econ log recently made the
point that many people overstate seem to
exaggerate their risk let them act on
that exaggeration which they should be
free to do lock downs are incredibly
expensive financially medically and for
our economic freedom lock downs of it
undoubtedly reduced some deaths but
voluntary action gets a good chunk of
the credit the government's making one
mistake after another and yet through
all this we flattened the curve let's
let the American people who've been
socially distancing who've been washing
their hands my hands are raw and doing
all those things let's let them act on
their own good sense the way the vast
majority of them are now I'll close with
this let's end the lock downs and let's
end them now thank you David that that
was perfectly within your time and
Justin you have same amount of time to
oppose the resolution take it away
Justin no dressing no it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be zoom it wouldn't be zoom if
I forgot if I didn't forget to run me
unmute myself so thank you Jane and
thanks David for kicking things off I
think so constructively let me tell you
where I'm coming from I'm an economist
I'm not a card-carrying libertarian
whether some of my best friends are and
you know so I think for me this counts
as an away game but I'm gonna have a
mocha my best crack anyway let me start
that I I think right now we face the
greatest public health crisis the
greatest economic crisis and potentially
the greatest financial crisis of my
lifetime probably of any of our
lifetimes given the gravity of that
situation I'm not going to try and win
the debate today I think that David's
annoyed my job is responsible public
intellectuals is to try to bring reason
to the debate and so when David makes a
really good point I'm not going to give
you a glib counter I'm going to
underline it and I'm going to emphasize
it and I'm going to tell you why you got
it right
I'm also the other thing I'm not going
to do is I'm not gonna play the role of
fake epidemiologist because I struggle
to even be an economist so if you want
to argue about an epidemiological study
out of Santa Clara County I'm just going
to punt on it but what I do need to do
is define the terms of the debate a
little bit the US economy should be
liberated from government lock downs
right away but I want to begin by
conceding a really important point here
the terms of the debate are not is this
a good moment for libertarians although
in many respects it is and so I want to
open by conceding that much of what what
David said is is exactly right we can
look at the response and see government
failure everywhere which is a an ongoing
theme of libertarian thought where you
can see excess regulation in various
parts of the federal government
particularly the FDA and some of the
drug approval processes we could see
concerns about monopoly power
potentially creating real problems
through supply chains right now we see
enormous rent-seeking from from big
corporations trying to get their
favorite favors written into the fiscal
rescue package so in many respects it is
time to tip my hat to my libertarian
friends and say many of the themes
you've been wanting us about for a long
long time have been exactly accurate I
can say all of that
environmentally disagree with the motion
which is that the US economy should be
liberated from government lockdowns
right away that let me be clear the
terms of the debate here are that it
should be liberated from government
lockdowns right away so the question is
not should the locked-down end there's
no question the lockdown should end the
question is when should the lockdown end
should it end right now now I was
invited to give to this debate I think
it was maybe ten ten days ago and
actually the longer time goes on the
stronger David's case is going to be
because eventually these lockdowns are
going to have to end because the public
health threats will be smaller and the
benefits of the lockdown will no longer
exceed the costs but as of today I feel
pretty confident on on my side of the
debate we've seen in the US the new
cases of coronavirus being diagnosed or
being confirmed the data here of course
are totally confused somewhat by the
extent to which we're testing but new
cases look like they may have peaked I
got my fingers crossed and I hope that's
true now it's important that none of us
mistake what that means the most
dangerous day in a pandemic is the day
with the highest number of new cases the
second most dangerous day is the day
after that we're pretty much in the
second most dangerous day right now and
so if there's any if there's any point
at which the demotion that I'm
supporting is true it was either true
yesterday or it's true today or it's
never been true so I'm in some sense on
my strongest possible grounds I think
it's important that what we don't do is
is fiddle about and debate you know
should we have a full lockdown except
for David Nye because we're the two
responsible people let's just say that
you know small variations on a lockdown
we'll call that a lockdown and small
variations on opening out we'll just
call it opening up so the thing that
David missed and so you know what I want
to do now is I just want to go ahead and
make you know six key points and that
the first is the one word David didn't
say once and as a fellow economist he
knows better than this
it didn't say the word externalities the
whole question here is one of
externalities that's economics jargon
for when I take actions that harm others
if I don't take others into account that
I'll do too much of that right
externalities the reason that we might
want to regulate the extent to which
factories can pollute the environment if
not factories will pollute as much as
they want and the rest of us have to
breed in the smog the externalities here
are far greater and far more serious if
I go if I walk down to the local park
and sneeze near three or four other
people I might kill them that's an
externality the basic economic logic is
if people are not forced to pay for the
costs of the damage they do to others
they'll do too much damage and so what
we want to do is we want to fix that
externality and the question is how to
fix that externality an economics
textbook
I just wrote one says will tell you that
with Nick's analogy you might want to
you might want to tax it away a tax of
course would be a great idea for global
warming we could have a carbon tax but
how do we tax social interactions that
might cause others to die that's almost
impossible we might want you know the
the standard libertarian argument is
let's invoke the Coase theorem and allow
people to make a bunch of side bargains
so that they don't do bad things to each
other but how do other people at the
park bribed me to not turn up to the
park to potentially infect them the
coast theorems clearly doesn't apply
here as it doesn't run so many other
issues and so I totally agree that a
shutdown is a very blunt instrument none
of most circumstances few economists
would be in favor of it it turns out
that the nature of this externality is
one that's very very difficult to time
using our alternative and otherwise
better tools and that's why for much of
what we need to do it's going to be some
form of regular of regulatory solution
either we prevent people from various
forms of social interaction or we don't
I'm arguing we should David arguing we
shouldn't so that's the logic and I
really think that's the terms upon which
the debate should proceed you either
think the externality is large and it's
very difficult to tainment using
alternative instruments or you argue
that the externality is somehow being
internalized
through some magic which I which no one
has yet explained to me so then the
question is is the externality large
enough to justify using this very sharp
form of government intervention so you
know what I think we should do what I
would do as an economist is a very
simple form of cost-benefit analysis so
the question first question is and I'm
going to do the absolute roughest
back-of-the-envelope but that's so that
we can all follow at home you're all
going to argue that I made small
mistakes along the way but it turns out
that when you're cost-benefit analysis
is so overwhelming in one direction you
don't have to go back and dot the i's
and cross the t's because it's already
clear what the right answer is in this
case let's think about the the benefits
of the shutdown using reasonable
epidemiological estimates let's say that
if we just let the disease rip a million
Americans would die we're going to get
it down to 60,000 hopefully so let's say
we've saved a million lives I get around
here let's use a standard cost of life
estimate the standard the American
government uses is we value life we
value it extraordinarily highly we think
each life is worth 10 million dollars
for those who think that economists
don't value human life they're exactly
wrong economists in this public debated
being more vociferous about suggesting
human life is deeply and profoundly
valuable so if we could save a million
lives a tear each worth 10 million
dollars you get out your calculator
you'll discover that's 10 trillion
dollars that's the benefit of the lock
down what's the cost well the cost is
that we're going to be producing less
I'm going to stick to the economic I
know David wants to talk about economic
freedom as well and I'm simply gonna let
my my libertarian friends who have
strong views about that than I am but
let's just stick to the standard
economic cost-benefit the cost is as
David said that economic activity has
slowed he said that and he's right the
US economy produces 20 trillion a year
so that's about five trillion a quarter
and he cited a recent forecast goldman
sachs is a standard source that GDP
growth next quarter will fall by 35
percent and then he said that that adds
up to a lot of money now actually it
turns out David made a very simple
mathematical mistake just there what the
government Sachs forecast is is that GD
people fall this is like the nerdiest
point I can make so like if you're get
leaned in and if you want to be
entertained I'm sorry GT
goldman-sachs forecast that GDP would
decline it an annualized rate of thirty
five percent in the next quarter an
annualized rate means this is the rate
that would occur if it continued for an
entire year Goldman Sachs is only
forecasting that GDP is going to decline
in one quarter so in fact Goldman Sachs
is predicting that GDP will decline by
about nine point nine percent let's
round and call that ten percent next
quarter so that in turn says that the
damage is one-third as large as David
had suggested so let's say that GDP
should be five trillion in the quarter
it declines by ten percent so it's going
to be five hundred billion that is how
much lower output will be so remember I
saved us ten trillion dollars worth of
human life and we're doing so at a cost
of five hundred billion that's a
stunning cost-benefit calculation now I
want to go on and make a related point
the 500 billion that we're going to lose
next quarter is not the cost of the lock
down that's how much worse output will
be as a result of the combination of
covert 19 and the lock down the real
question is how much worse is economic
activity going to be as a result of the
lock down with covert compared to not
having a lock down and still having
covered there's a reasonable argument to
be made in fact that the economy will
performs more strongly as a result of
beating the bug than simply letting it
rip so it may be even if I concede
everything David once he's at 500
billion versus my 10 trillion but I
don't want to concede even that he may
even have the sign wrong it may actually
be that a locked-down infected economy
outperforms a non lockdown infected
economy and that's the relevant
perspective here so one of the things I
hope all of the audience takes from this
is it's really important not to confuse
the costs of coronavirus which are
massive and devastating with the cost of
the lockdown
the lockdown is meant to ameliorate the
cost of the virus so the next thing that
the lockdown is doing is preventing the
possibility of a second breakup and
that's the reason why I feel confident
Aveo need to stick with the lockdown
suffer quite a bit longer the IMF have
done some projections where they looked
at what would happen if we had a second
outbreak and their argument is that the
economic casts as in the reduced output
caused by covert 19 could be twice or
three times larger than what we're
currently looking at putting it back
into the terms of this debate the
benefit of the lockdown if it prevents a
second outbreak is two or three times
larger than I've said so far finally I
just want to come back and I think they
bar for me to win this debate is
incredibly low because at the end of
this debate it could be you think on
balance David's right he's most likely
to be right perhaps he is but there's
some chance that I am if David's right
then you know we got a little bit of a
lockdown going on for a few weeks longer
we'll all be okay if the worst of the
epidemiological models are right then
hundreds and thousands hundreds of
thousands potentially even millions of
people may end up dying as a result of
this so the balance of risks here is
incredibly asymmetric you only need to
put a small probability on me being
right to think that
lockdowns make sense from a public
policy perspective and I think one of
them I can do better than that gene
because I'm about to adjourn because I
just want people to think about its this
is one of those cases where good
decisions aren't based on what you think
is most likely to happen it's based on
the full distribution of risks the full
distribution of risks ranges from
everything so overblown and hardly
anyone's going to die from coronavirus
right so that would be thick wears
60,000 lives better off than we think we
are to 2 million 3 million 4 million
Americans might die I think those are
unbelievably high numbers I don't take
them seriously but I do think the
distribution of risks it's not - 60,000
plus 60,000 it's - - 60,000 plus 2
million and that distribution of risks I
think pushes one to
it's making the case for continuing to
look tense so let me stop there and it's
just because I want to hear more of what
David's got to say okay um Justin thank
you very much
this certainly that was very gracious
presentation aside from other merits in
what you said David you have again five
minutes to rebut so please take it away
okay and I'll do my best I was you kind
of beat me to it
to some extent Jean I want to say it's
very gracious in your part and I'm just
really glad the debate is going the way
it is so first of all I want to just
acknowledge that you you pointed out
these government failures and by the way
if these government failures hadn't
happened if the FDA hadn't been able to
prevent these things we might not even
be having this debate because we might
have had all kinds of ways of testing
now you said that I missed externalities
you're right in the narrow sense I
didn't use the word externalities but I
did implicitly talk about them if there
weren't externalities there be I would
have won the debate from the get-go in
other words there are no externalities
but I I grant that there are
externalities and that's by the way why
I emphasized I think I emphasized that
many people are very nervous about this
and they aren't gonna stop social
distancing just because the government
ends the lockdown and so a lot of the
externalities are being handled by
people's behavior and again remember so
the the in in Italy the average age of
someone who - this is 80 point five
years the United States 78 percent of
the people who died from this so far are
over age 65 so it's that's why I
emphasize the people most at risk can
stay indoors and so that solves a lot of
it you're right the Coase theorem I'm
not going to go there the Coase theorem
is not relevant for a bunch of reasons
we're talking to tens of millions of
people we're talking we don't even know
who has it and one reason we don't even
know who has it
because of course the government has
held up these tests now that the
cost-benefit analysis I think that's our
biggest difference Justin talked about 1
million Americans potentially dying I
simply think that's run realistic and if
you look though they then way those
numbers have come down is a result of
two things social distancing which I'm
in favor of and then practicing as is
Justin and lockdowns which I'm against
and we've got to separate those out the
value of life that's a standard thing
we've used and by the way that's a
thinking on the margin thing as I
mentioned what's the marginal impact of
the lock down the value of life that's a
number I've used I talk cost-benefit
analysis for about 20 years at the Naval
Postgraduate School
I've actually been led to question that
and let me tell you why
Luigi Zingales had a piece a few last
month in which he said he had a high
number seven million people might be
killed and he said with a nine million
dollar value of life that's three years
of GDP and I started thinking about that
as saying does that make sense
would it make sense to cut down three
years of GDP to save seven million lives
when cutting down three years of GDP is
probably going to lead to the loss of 50
million lives and there's a big overlap
between the 50 million and the 7 million
so it's a reductio ad absurdum and I
think for these kinds of numbers we have
to take that seriously the Goldman Sachs
thing I'm gonna I'm pretty sure I'm
right on that Justin if it falls at a 30
person is 3035 percent annual rate then
then during that quarter we lose 35
percent of output now how long do I have
to well you say you're right I'm not
sure you're right I'm not sure how long
do I have to yeah yeah how long do I
have
gene how do i how long do I have okay
okay so I think what was happening here
is we have very bad information so
imagine some new world in which someone
else comes some other disease comes
along we don't know much about it if you
say okay we're gonna take the most
extreme assumptions which by the way
involve no one responding to the
incentives and no one responding to the
risk which is what these models assume
we're gonna have these every few years
at least that's quite conceivable
because there are gonna be other biases
there are gonna be other viruses and
we're gonna have the government doing
this every few years maybe it's every 10
years but Justin you set up front this
is the greatest public health financial
economic crisis in your lifetime
certainly financial and economic I grant
you and I'm not sure about public health
but you're young I'm old and you got a
longer lifetime and there might be other
public health crises and just giving the
government this incredible power when
they know so little is a bad idea all
right thank you David
Justin your rebuttal take it away five
minutes
great thank you um I want to come back
to three important points that David
made and they are important the first is
he he took me on the right terms you
said let's talk about costs and benefits
the basic numbers I laid out over very
close to what I've read now you know a
dozen different estimates by various
economists some are higher than mine
some are lower than mine I'm not here to
convince anyone I get the right number I
tend to think one should be humble at a
time like this and so what I tried to
represent is a rough consensus of
cost-benefit analyses across the
economics profession and for sure it's
possible to jack up the costs and Jack
down the benefits in order to fit some
particular story but I think I've tried
to honestly represent the median view
among economists
David wants to quibble about two
important things and I think that buzz
really critical good thing when we're
talking about benefit because he only
wants to quibble about the benefit in
the cost
so let's talk about those the benefit
you know I suggested maybe we've saved a
million lives by having a lock down he
says very very reasonably that when we
think about this we're talking about the
effect of the lock down we need to
realize that even in the absence of the
lock down people would have taken a lot
of private precautions and so is it
reasonable to believe that a million
people would have died absent the lock
down here I think the answer is yes I
think the critique of epidemiological
models that they don't take this into
account sufficiently strongly this is a
critique of economy by economists of
epidemiological models that people
change their behavior and response to
incentives and the chance that you might
die is a strong incentive and so it
leads them to take precautions private
precautions the debate today is about
public precautions is right but to
David's point New York right now one out
of one out of every five hundred eighty
two New Yorkers has died so if you scale
that sort of estimate up to the United
States as a whole that gets you to half
a million Americans and that's using New
York which is not yet finished with its
epidemic so all of this says it is
absolutely quite realistic to believe
that absence serious interventions we
would see a million people die so the
benefits I think are genuine genuinely
substantial on the costs I think getting
the quantification of this stuff right
is really really important the thing
that's different about this economic
downturn right now is it's the most
rapid we've ever seen it's also very
deeper but the costs of a downturn or a
product not just how deep it is but also
its duration again I don't know what's
going to happen to the economy but I do
know what the consensus forecasts from
private sector forecasters are saying
and if you look at the total amount of
lost output over time most private
sector forecasters see the economy
bouncing back relatively quickly so the
total cost of this downturn is
absolutely serious it may be as large as
it may be about two-thirds that of the
financial crisis
but it's not a Great Depression in fact
it's not even 1/10 of a Great Depression
so it's important to keep that in mind I
noticed in the comments people worrying
about a million people being homeless
this downturn is going to be incredibly
costly but it's not going to cause that
massive scale of dislocation the second
thing David said I wanted to come back
to is his comparisons with the flu he
said well this is as bad as the flu
60,000 people have died 60,000 people
normally die of the flu now the thing to
realize is 60,000 people will die in the
United States in one month his number is
that 60,000 people died of the flu in
one year and in fact if you look over
the last 10 years 60,000 people have
died from the flu and only one out of
the last ten years in fact already
covered 19 looks to be 4 to 5 times more
deadly than the flu is on average but it
doesn't matter because actually David's
points really good it's really helpful
for my case because he's saying look the
flu kills so many people do you know a
really good way of preventing the flu
spreading and killing lots of people
having a shutdown so we're not just
going to save lives because we prevent
the spread of Kovan we're going to save
more lives because we spread prevent the
spread of the flu as well so David
David's point here goes my way
the final thing he says and I think this
is absolutely critical which is we need
to distinguish between the economic that
could the cost of a shutdown a lock down
versus social distancing and he's right
what does a lock down dude well before
the lock down 90% of us with social
distancing so what the lock down does is
it makes 10 percent more people socially
distant these are the people who didn't
care much about their own lives before
presumably they didn't care much about
others these may well be the super
spreaders these may be the people we
really really need to cut down but even
if that's not true if even without the
government locked down we do 90% of this
distancing and 90% of us would stay at
home what that says is that the benefits
over the lock down are only 10% as large
but so are the costs of the lock down so
David's point I can concede it entirely
it's an important one what it says is
this entire debate about whether to have
lock downs if in the absence of a lock
down we'd have a 90 percent lock down
then it
like all he's saying is the present
debate that he and I are having is only
10% as important as he and I used to
think it was but if he's going to use
this 10% to knock down the benef the
cost of the the benefits of looked at he
does need to use the temps in to knock
down the class in equal measure look he
said no one should be at forced to
confront risks that they don't actually
choose and I agree with that and that
sounds like a libertarian principle the
only but I'm not going to be able to go
to a public park a shopping center a
school without confronting risks unless
we can beat the bug unless we can
eliminate it and that's what the
lockdowns are all about thank you thank
you Justin
we now move to the Q&A portion of the
evening and at any time one debater or
the other is free to ask the other
debater a question David do you have a
question for Justin Justin do you have a
question for David that's your option at
the moment go ahead thank you okay
Justin you said at one point that this
might just be a few weeks longer where's
your cutoff what do you look for in
order to say yes let's end the lockdown
lockdown what would you have to see um
so I'm gonna live up to my promise
earlier of not being a bad public health
official so I don't have a full point
plan I do think that you know why I
would want well the most important right
the obvious one that everyone agrees on
I think is we need to make sure that the
hospital system is not overwhelmed
that's the whole flat into curved logic
I think we want to go a step further and
want to feel quite confident that the
rate of transmission what the
epidemiologists call are is
substantially less than one and likely
to be sustainably so so our is how many
if I get covered how many other people
will get it as a result of me and if
that numbers more than one then we go
into this exponential growth exponential
like growth where millions get it
millions die so I want to see are
substantially below one and they want
epidemiology public health officials to
be able to assure me that a move to
private actions social distancing he's
gonna keep our below one because
otherwise we're gonna move straight back
into this and we're gonna have a second
cycle is that responsive they might I
think it is can I ask a following
oh yes yes okay so look at South Dakota
which doesn't have a lock down it said
seven deaths so far what would you say
so I just like you did I don't have a
really good formulate a question but
think about South Dakota are they doing
it badly and I think you would have to
say yes but if you do if so why if not
why not
so I will answer your question but I'm
gonna do it in a roundabout way I'm
gonna say the most painful words and
Australian has ever said look at New
Zealand look at New Zealand within a
couple of weeks there'll be no cases in
New Zealand zero New Zealand had the
most dramatic lockdown I think pretty
much of any country they've got the
advantage of being an island and so it's
easy to prevent it getting back in and
so for larger island economies this
seems like an incredibly useful way
forward and so David your questions
about South Dakota so this is a case
where you know when you've got
incredibly low population density it may
be that the natural transmission rate is
very very low this is so like why I
began that about saying if your argument
is we should have lock downs nearly
everywhere but not in South Dakota we're
not really disagree in much are we now I
do think that I am very worried about
what's going on in the south with the
southern governors removing lockdowns
early or saying that they're going to
remove lock downs earlier you know it's
a little bit like having a ping end of
the swimming pool you're allowed to pay
up this in but not that end I don't want
to get in that pool and frankly I don't
want to live in a country in which folks
in the South are allowed to pay out
coronavirus and so that is coming back
to government failure a national policy
here makes a hell of a lot of sense and
I am really worried about the damage
that the South could do to the rest of
the country just in any question for
David or
at this point let's go to the the you
get a lot of other people here and
they've got great questions we've had I
actually do want to intervene and say
you know fairness that it is true as as
a economic journalist for 25 years who
tracked the GDP numbers Justin is
technically correct that that if that
indeed by the way Japan does not earn
you a lot of your customer Japan does
not annualize their numbers but though
it but they habit for the Bureau of
Economic Analysis is to annualize every
change in quarterly GDP so Justin is
technically correct that that a thirty
five percent decline is an annualized
number and that if you actually
calculate the loss you have to de
annualize it approximately divided by
four so what I do want to say that as
somebody who's tracked the numbers for
about a quarter of a century
I think he's divided twice though
because I already took I think you
divided twice I took a quarter of GDP is
five trillion so if you lose 30 percent
of it for that quarter oh well no no
that's one point five trillion no no the
truth is David that if you actually look
at the decline in GDP that is say it's
essentially like a nine percent decline
in GDP and then in terms of actual
dollars and then they take that nine
percent and then they annualize it they
take it to the fourth power that is
actually what they do they double
analyze it's it's guaranteed to create
confusion I'll call this you can call it
government finally here's my commitment
Justin I will end you I will back off on
that if I'm right I'm gonna post on or
an econ vlog and if I'm wrong I'm gonna
push start an econ log okay okay okay
and this was this was an unusual moment
in which a the moderator ganged up
against one side very noble of me
since I happen to be a libertarian
myself but but indeed I it really is
true David and you'll post it because
you're very honest guy but but that one
of the questions that came in and
actually a question in my mind just
was this this point about calculating
the the human life and the ten million
first of all even in in terms of the way
that it's formulated doesn't it come to
a different number for example when it
comes to an of an 80 year old versus the
life of a thirty year old isn't aren't
those drastically different numbers and
isn't the the technical calculation you
made a little bit different for starters
because we're mostly talking about
people over sex 65 70 know they know 10
million people 10 million dollar babies
it's an excellent question so your so
let me be totally clear when the US
government sets regulations about a
range of things from speed limits to
backup cameras on cars they often face
these trade-offs between we're gonna
save this many lives versus not and we
need to compare this to the dollars and
so what we use is a value of a
statistical life the US government is
decided to use ten million dollars and
there's good economic studies that
suggest that's a reasonable thing to do
as a matter of policy so this is not an
argument this is just a matter of policy
the government has decided to value all
lives the same black white young or old
now you may have an intuition that
that's crazy that a 80 year old has
fewer years to live than an 8 year old
and we should think about them
differently but just as a descriptive
matter that's not how government policy
is implemented the question the question
you ask there's a good on which is let's
take your idea seriously and so let's
knock my value of a life from 10 million
dollars down to 3 million dollars the
cost-benefit calculation I gave you the
imbalance was so great nothing changes
and then look let me just add for your
listeners is a wonderful there's a very
nice paper by Chad Jones Bob Hall and
Pete clean out at Stanford where they
take your idea gene very very seriously
and they suggest that if you take your
idea as seriously as as you might want
the value of the lock the lockdown will
be worth it if it can come at a cost of
reducing consumption by less than 25
percent for a year I think it's going to
end up being less than 25 percent you
could make an economic card when it's
going to be greater than that so it is
going to get a lot closer actually do
you have a comment on that David
yeah just again the key number though
isn't we're actually in the same range
roughly with the value of life long as I
said with the luigi's and Gollust thing
it may be a little nervous about how
wide a range we can do that in but I
think the key number is a million which
i think is unrealistic I don't know the
I'm trying to follow the rules and
Justin is a very great guy at this and
so can I just make a statement without
asking a question let him James
I can pose it as a question so let's say
you could require everyone who goes out
or they're around other people to have a
really good mask and to have really good
gloves isn't that like a fraction of the
cost of what's going on and would that
do it for you and is it a matter of not
trusting people because they get in the
business and they rip all that stuff
offer I just like to understand how you
think about that yeah so here I think
we're really close to agreeing which is
there's a bad externality the usual
market-based mechanisms for getting rid
of the externality don't work so we need
a heavy-handed regulation yours is a
very heavy-handed regulation from a
libertarian perspective which is you
would force everyone to wear as mask and
gloves and if you could prevent if those
if those masks was sufficiently rigorous
that you could guarantee me that you
know I'm not going to kill anyone when I
go to the local park we've solved the
externality okay and that's got a lock
down just notice that's not a lock down
right so is a regulation absolutely I I
want to solve the externality I want to
solve it in the cheapest way possible I
can't do it through the market so I'm
gonna use heavy-handed regulation it
would offend the libertarian
sensibilities in normal times but among
the menu of regulations let's choose the
lowest cost one
you got me brother well I'm sad what's
the last thing you said Justin yeah you
said about I said you've got me he wins
let me look since I've been a little bit
aggressive let me point out Justin that
libertarians accept restraining orders
imposed by courts and so this is really
in the in the category of a restraining
order that that a court would impose so
it's really not that offensive to
libertarians so if you've said Justin
that you simply pass a rule which of
course most people would abide by freely
because they don't want to hurt other
people and they want to protect
themselves that everybody has the
precaution of the mask and the gloves
and that it has to happen in the
workplace as well then we can avoid the
lockdown and and and and David gets his
way
is there not can I tell you where this
is really important so right now when
the business community is talking to the
White House they're saying the biggest
reason we refuse to open is because
we're worried that we're going to be
liable for covered that spread in the
workplace
and they're asking the federal
government don't make me liable for one
of my co-workers killing another and I
think if you took libertarian principles
seriously and if you took the Coast
theer remotely seriously and if you took
economic ideas seriously you absolutely
want the employer to be liable there
they're the least cost avoid a we want
to make people responsible for the
consequences of their actions and I
would be at the moment it's a very
left-wing position to be saying no way
businesses have to be liable for actions
that kill their workers but I would be
delighted if my libertarian friends join
me in that call for responsibility yes
you can if you can just show with the
very high probability that that's where
the person got it yeah absolutely we you
and I've got some details to work out
but reliability in the workplace yeah
well well yeah again I take it Justin
that you don't believe that this is
necessarily offensive to libertarians
because because there's a whole body of
libertarian rules and red
having to do with restraining orders and
having to do indeed with harm that
people do to each other that's the what
I prefer to call the zero aggression
principle and if somebody is is guilty
of severe neglect then indeed they can
be sued or they are liable so it's all
quite libertarian so welcome to the fold
of libertarians it looks like this is a
key moment for for you especially on but
I want to ask and as a matter of fact
David's question was anticipated by
somebody in the audience that indeed the
other way we can go about it is simply
to require that those 10% of people who
are responsible
most people would indeed not want to
harm others that there be a crackdown on
them because as you said Justin they are
imposing danger on other people
but then with respect to your you use
the phrase quite a bit longer that this
you did indeed say that and maybe you
want to and you're not necessarily
responsible for it but in terms of the
cost a number of questions are coming in
one of the questions is that that while
economists make interesting statements
about the harm to human life health
morbidity and and a misery from economic
downturns that people do commit suicide
more often people do turn to drugs and
alcohol a lot of cost there potentially
and another question that came in is
apart from our issue about the quarterly
annualization of a downturn if you said
quite a bit longer that sounds you like
you're almost annualizing it for a whole
year potentially and then apart from
that another question that came in a lot
of lot of libertarians out there that
are on your case that a question how
about those trillions of dollars that
the Federal Reserve is printing the huge
increase in debt the the indebtedness
that were in current from all this which
is going to continue the more we
continue the lock down so how about the
deaths and then on top of that another
question that came in which underscores
David's point a lot of these people are
already got not going to die because
they're old people like me and like
David we're not going to go outside
anyway
so we're not going to die even if the
lockdown is lifted so that's a lot of
questions that came in attacking you
Justin so you're gonna get about six
minutes to answer go ahead please I
think I started by saying that this was
gonna be an away game for me and I think
you just just convinced me of that let
me let me actually
oh there's two issues I want to speak to
specifically and then I'll ignore the
others just because I can't answer six
things at the same time but you should
come back to me with the ones you want
me to hit okay someone you pointed out
there's beyond the purely economic costs
downturns are far more costly look I'm a
center-left economist absolutely
downturns suck one of the things I study
is happiness downturns have a big effect
on happiness well over and above any
effect that you would think just because
people lost income so the simple back of
the envelope I gave was far too simple
but when we start to get into these
second-order things it's not gonna
whatever turn that logic but I do want
to acknowledge suicides are almost
certainly gonna go up here rates of
depression are almost certainly gonna go
up interestingly though in this way I
wanted to come back to this point deaths
are not going to go up it turns out
there's a nice literature studying the
effects of recessions on health the only
cause of death that goes up during a
recession is suicide but actually almost
every other cause of death goes down
during recession for fairly obvious
reasons traffic accidents go down right
we're out driving less but heart attacks
go down because if you think about what
you're doing during an economic boom
you're you're working all day every day
you're making hay while the Sun shines
and so it's actually quite clear that
recessions actually tend to increase the
quantity of life now the flip side is
I'm pretty sure they reduce the quality
of life so not for a moment by
suggesting we should have more
recessions but simply to say what you're
worried about is lives the economic
downturn is actually more likely to help
than to hurt the other thing is when we
start thinking about these extra things
that I didn't account for you've got to
do it on both sides of the equation so
it's absolutely the case that
unemployment will cause depression and
misery the other thing is deaths are not
the only course cost of covered
one there's enormous anxiety and I'm
sure many of you particularly those of
you with older parents can feel that
anxiety every day but also for those who
recover there's permanent scarring of
the lungs and actually the number of
people who recover is so much larger
than the number of people who die that
you don't have to put a very high price
on how valuable is it to avoid permanent
scarring of the lungs to think there are
even larger health benefits from
avoiding more you know broader a broader
spread of traveied let you comment I'll
let you comment David go ahead cuz
Justin told me to repeat a couple of
questions in that necessarily answer do
you want to comment and what Jessica
said well actually no I think I kind of
agree I just want to go back though to
the point about employer liability I
like the idea of employer liability when
the employer does something that could
be known in advance to cause a problem
I'm not you look why are we even having
this debate because we don't know it's
this invisible thing it's out there we
can't necessarily test for beeped espy
before and we keep hearing as
asymptomatic and that's a big part of it
so people come to work the employer
takes their temperature Disneyland said
if they're gonna go back and business
they're going to take people's
temperature and if they do all those
things and it turns out someone got it
so I don't think employer liability
necessarily get you very far and it can
be a big setup and now let's be
realistic about juries it's not like
juries are looking at the value of a
life and saying oh this person lost this
many quality life years you'll see
people with very sketchy evidence you're
giving someone a hundred and fifty
million dollars you know I when I wake
up in the middle night and can't sleep I
see these ads on TV all the time and so
employer liability isn't this great
solution um do you want to comment
Justin or yeah you look David's right we
know enough about how tort reform works
tort law works to know that the way it
works now textbooks is not the way it
always
works in our lives I still think
allowing the employer not to be liable
at all and the employer allowing
customers to come through would infect
me and co and setting up workplaces is
actually a really really bad idea
Jean you asked earlier about taking us a
step further saying instead of banning
people if I go to the local park and I
infect other people then I should be
liable for that and as an economist I
love that idea it's the Coase theorem
again it internalizes the externality it
would potentially solve everything the
problem with it is twofold one if you
catch Cove it at the local playground
you don't know who you got it from into
the defendants have small pockets the
nice thing about employer liabilities
you've got defendants with deep pockets
and big incentives to to avoid those
expensive yes well yes no no that the
questioner the question here and
actually that was David's initiative as
well simply saying that you you have
rules and revs that that guess of that
that are imposed that say that not as
you indicate the the difficulty of
proving anything or with respect to
going to the park as you indicate is not
something you can easily do but the idea
was simply that people are are told that
you've got to wear the mask you've got
it with the gloves you've got to take
precautions and if you're found not
doing sell and I guess you've got to
find then then then that's the idea of
prevention which is a form of
restraining order that you can't go
within so that's this so that's the idea
and David we're suggesting that if we if
we let's say we impose that in a very
draconian way wouldn't like that satisfy
you as sufficient because you seem to
acknowledge that old people like me are
gonna stay inside anyway a lot of us are
going to take precautions we're probably
are not going to go near crazy teenagers
and other other doofuses who who tend to
play with their lives dangerously so a
lot of that will sort itself out anyway
and then on top of that restrictions
will be imposed
perhaps by anybody well I run the scylla
forum I'd like to put people in order to
and I of course I'm in wrestling with
what I will do because obvious I don't
want anybody to die but certainly people
are not going to be admitted if they
misbehave in any way they will be told
to leave so all of those restrictions
that imposed by business and imposed by
government aren't they enough for you
and wouldn't you want to then lift the
lockdown that was David's question and
the question is up getting from the
audience no no do I think private
precautions are enough to solve things
well nothing is enough nothing's enough
but again you find people the private
but course no I said the government
would caution to the government imposes
a rule that says well however you want
to write it you've got to wear a mask
you've gotta wear gloves
you can't certain things are not allowed
that's prevented - that's like a
restraining order
that doesn't mean you cause something
but it means you're putting people in
jeopardy unnecessarily and that is
easily something you can be prosecuted
for a fine for because you're putting
people's lives in danger that seem to be
was that was the drift of your
suggestion David well I do is that
correct David yeah actually I noticed
and I'm mostly paying attention to what
people are saying every once in a while
I'm looking at the chap this is kind of
new to me but I did notice mark Bonner
had I think how you say mark ba-bah NER
had a kind of an idea which is you look
for reasonable precautions if the
employer took reasonable precautions
he's bulletproof and I think that's kind
of reasonable okay that's the employer
but then the individual I thought you
said require masks similar to the
questions I'm saying requirement or
whatever requirements seem to be good
that that a better impose with
punishment fines and if you maybe if
you're a three-time loser maybe some
even worst punishment for for taking a
Liberty with other people's lives would
that be enough for you Justin my concern
with this is the damage that you can do
to others is so great that the fines
would have to be astronomical to a
degree that I think most people couldn't
pay them right so if I were to go and
kill three people and we think a human
life is worth 10 million dollars then I
would be liable for 30 million dollars
good luck collecting that and because of
that I'm not going to bother taking a
ton of precautions so it's it's simply
the shallow pockets theoretically Jen I
love that idea and we can use it for
lots of domains where the stakes aren't
so high but here the stakes are too high
to rely on that okay the other question
that that does if I was you did use you
did use the term quite a bit longer and
also and in terms of cost so that could
go into a couple of other calendar
quarters which where the annualization
would begin to become annual and also
the question that came in was all about
these trillions of dollars the other
course that the government is in current
long-term the indebtedness that we are
incurring because of this all of those
are costs as well but the so could you
deal with those costs and then also
address the question how much longer at
what point will you be arguing for
David's position as you very generously
said you will at some point do right so
now I'm going to play my only glib
debating point trick of the day okay the
motion the motion was the US economy
should be liberated from government
lockdowns right away on the motion I'm
all in on that now if we have this
debate in a week's time
I'm still going to be there because
we're still going to be losing 2000
Americans everyday and we'll still be at
a very very dangerous point but I'm open
to it i the thing that's really
important and I should say is for people
who are on my side of this debate we
need to be ready to totally change our
minds and totally change our talking
points the moment it becomes clear that
the costs of that that the that it looks
like we got the bug beat and figuring
out what that is that's going to be the
most difficult intellectual challenge
I'm going to face over the next couple
of months none of that you know
particularly answers your question
but you know I feel very comfortable
this situation for at least a couple
more weeks and then I'd want to look at
the evidence and if we had clear
evidence of
Jews transmission below one and some
experiments from other countries or
particular States showing that privates
social isolation was sufficient to keep
us beating the bug then I jump on but at
the moment you know there was a very
good question one of your colleagues
asked someone in the audience asked no
I'm sorry I can't sit on my screen right
now which was you know look it's also in
fact it was Andrew no it wasn't Andrew
it was Frank Gambino he says there are
so many variables and so many unknown
numbers that any central planning seems
more absurd than usual I gotta say I'm
pretty confident this is a bug that
could go out and kill a [ __ ] ton of us I
don't want to go less a fair against a
virus less a fair seems exactly the
wrong answer for a virus if you think
about all of the uncertainties the
uncertainties are bounded from the best
possible outcome is you know we're gonna
stop dying tomorrow the worst possible
outcome is we've got another couple of
million people and the line and so if
you think about these uncertainties
these uncertainties move you towards
excessive action the sorts of action you
would think on average will be excessive
because we're worried about those states
of nature where in fact things really do
turned out much worse than we currently
expect I see uh any coming from you
David on that well again I think the
difference is that the justin is way
overstating the deaths do I know that no
but he doesn't either and I just so
let's agree that we don't know and write
down a probability distribution would
you result it on seed yeah write down a
probability distribution about the
number of deaths and you have to concede
but remember Frank Knight's distinction
between risk and uncertainty uncertainty
this is uncertainty we don't know what
probability distribution what are you
gonna do then
I say we open up and see what happens I
say we do that your community not mine
oh we're there
we're there in fact let me point out can
I point out something about my community
I brought this along
I live in Monterey County four hundred
and thirty four thousand people we have
a guy named Edward Moreno he's the
health guy who basically persuaded the
Board of Supervisors to do the lockdown
in Monterey County he presented last
week here's what he said he said that
his data show that the county should
have about 9,000 cases now and 300
hospitalizations at this point last week
what have they actually counted a
hundred and eight cases and 22 people
who needed to be hospitalized so he was
off by an order of magnitude did that
change him at all no it did not
he's saying that six weeks from now
we're gonna have with the social
distancing rules he calls me I called
the lockdown in place we're gonna have
33,000 people sick with coronavirus so
what's happening is I'm not an
epidemiologist either Justin but like
you I understand statistics maybe I was
offering GDP I don't know but anyway I
understand statistics and when your
model is off by an order of magnitude
you throw out the model or you do a
major adjustment so the Libby if you
work with these models and any of these
epidemiologic models the problem is that
the moment you light the bug out you can
get exponential growth in the number of
cases but exponential ish to be
technical the implication of that is
that the errors even if you believe
fully in the models you talk to the
models you say what is your error range
will also be literally orders of
magnitude so I want to be clearly there
in the best possible guide we have to
the future of the coronavirus could get
the number of zeros wrong that's
absolutely true but you know I might
have been an economist too long I don't
know what to do without a model we got
to make decisions about the future
on that note on that note we actually
are out of time for the QA and then
you're gonna get your seven minutes of
summation and Justin and you have your
seven and a half minutes coming up in a
moment
David so please take it away with your
summation okay I don't think I'm gonna
use seven and a half because we've we've
covered the territory yeah so let me
just okay let's do this let me say where
I think we are and where the big
differences are and one thing that I
want to correct about something Justin
said where we are is that the government
failed massively
and that same government and same
bunches of governments that failed
massively just and trust to do the right
thing now and notice what I want to go
back to Eric Garcetti the mayor of LA I
mean he actually said let me let me get
the court again he actually said the
worst thing would be to lift the
floodgates and watch all of your friends
and neighbors die all of your friends
and neighbors that's crazy and so if
he's trying to scare people that way
that's not helping anything that's just
you know try trying to make people panic
um on the on the value of life I don't
think Justin and not that you should
because that you I just stated this an
hour ago and and it's new to me but I
don't think we can just use that 10
million when we're - if we are talking a
huge number of lives and I think the
Luigi Luigi Zingales reductio ad
absurdum shows it if it's really 10
million and and he says you would have
saved 7 million lives then that's three
years of GDP so if your model is telling
you that you should cut GDP to zero for
three years knowing it'll kill 50
million people instead of seven million
people there's something badly wrong
with your model I want to also get to a
point that I left unanswered because it
wasn't my turn and that was when Justin
made the point about the 90 percent of
the 10
if ninety percent of us are kind of you
know doing everything right
socially distancing wearing masks when
we go out all that thing and I don't
know if it's naughty but it it's a large
percent its way low whatever half I'm
positive
that's well then what's the big problem
he says because we've already got a lot
of that lock down no it's very different
because the lockdown is about
governments saying you can't do all
these things you can't go to work even
if you could go to work and comply
completely I have an office I rent above
a shoe store beside it is a real estate
firm at its peak at its peak there are
five people in that real estate firm
it's approximately a thousand square
feet they could easily social distance
if they tried to have that firm open the
cops would be by and shut them down
so that's why you really do need to
distinguish between social distancing
and lockdowns they aren't the same
lockdowns are this big hammer this big
blunt hammer Gretchen Whitmer saying you
can't fish you can't operate a motorboat
all those things people around here yeah
I don't know here but certainly parts of
California getting arrested for being in
their car and looking at a sunset people
getting arrested for being in their cars
in Mississippi and listening to a
reverend even though no one is
connecting with anyone else
physically other than people and their
family so you've really got to
distinguish between social distancing
and lockdowns one is not a percent of
the other I want I know I've got time so
let me just see if there's anything else
I want to say and I guess the other
thing I want to say is that when I
entered a debate with someone I don't
know I'm always afraid of whether the
person will use dirty tricks and I've
got to say Justin I've very much enjoyed
the tenor of this debate I mean you're a
real gentleman we are we are both
members of the Commonwealth and it shows
right so I just wanted to tell you how
much I appreciate that
Justin please give us your summation I
said I wouldn't stop by thanking David
as well for the brilliantly scholarly
approach he takes to this as he takes to
everything David's final coming and the
hammer which he wielded over me as he
said in this moment Justin wants to
trust the government which is a very
bitter pill for me to swallow given this
current government and he's right but I
want to think about the flip side of
this so I am trusting the government to
try to keep to try to keep us safe
that's what my proposal my side of the
floor is arguing the alternative is
either to trust the bug not to kill me
and I don't trust it or it's to trust
other people to take sufficient account
of my life my well-being my livelihood
and my value of his person that they
won't infect me and I don't trust him
that's the simple economics of
externalities people are taking making
choices where they're risking other
people's lives you've seen the photos of
spring break in Florida that's the logic
of externalities they're making bad
choices for others they're putting
others at risk
I don't like trust in the government I
don't have a better choice David David's
argument at the very end there lockdowns
or a hammer he's absolutely right could
we find slightly better ways of
designing these things I'm just going to
concede that you probably should be
allowed to fish which we're not allowed
to do in Michigan right now but by jingo
I'm glad that most workplaces are closed
I'm glad that schools are closed and I'm
glad that nursing homes are well
protected so could we design a better
lockdown I totally agree if the
alternative though remember the motion
was to liberate us from lock downs the
alternative no lockdown is something
that I worry a lot about David had what
he called a reductive
where he said he took my numbers and he
said doesn't this imply that you're
willing to give up a lot of GDP in order
to beat the bug the answer is I am
economists placed at enormous ly high
value on life it's funny to see how a
caricature and public debates as being
you know not at all interested in people
in their lives but actually the people
who are shouting most loudly in the
public debate to protect life is my
fellow economists and we do this because
that's how people act people make
choices as if they value their lives
that's where the value of statistical
life comes from so it's effectively
giving voice to the set of concerns that
they have another domains of their lives
look I just want to come back and say
you know I actually did my homework for
tonight's debate I knew I was kept
playing an away game talking to my
libertarian friends it's like oh is this
just gonna be a debate about philosophy
so I looked at my good friend John
Stuart Mill and Mel of course says the
only purpose for which power can be
rightfully exercised over any member of
a civilized community against his will
and that's what we're talking about
tonight is to prevent harm to others and
that's been precisely the case that I've
been making mill goes on and this is an
important part of libertarian thinking
his own good either physical or moral is
not a sufficient warrant and I hope
you've noticed that I've managed to make
my case tonight without being in any
state liberal trying to tell you how to
live a better life for your sake it's
actually about trying to make sure that
you don't harm others which is what mill
had in mind so look this is always going
to be a tough game to win on an away
pitch so I hope I might have persuaded
some of you or as David would say at the
margin but if not I think there's a
really important role for libertarians
moving forward this is a period in which
we've seen the most rapid change in the
role of government in our lives it's not
a government that plays by the usual
rules and there are going to be many
many rules and regulations special
favors dealt out which my libertarian
friends I think you're going to play a
really really important role in speaking
up and making sure that our government
doesn't undermine our civil liberties
that
doesn't do too many and too many favors
to special interest and awake and I
think it is a really important time for
each of you to be really involved in the
policy debate and we're gonna find
common ground on lots of these issues
going forward okay thank you to you both
for a clash of ideas that shed a lot of
light and very little heat because you
guys obviously like each other and it
was indeed a very civil debate which is
what we like at the Silph forum and as
Justin said it is a marginal issue with
respect to voting
you know how Oxford spell voting works
it's a it's a before and after situation
whoever moves the vote in his favor wins
the tootsie roll and so in that sense
the votes you get in your favor
initially count against you it's the
marginal achievement that matters and I
asked all of those in the audience
listening to vote now because we are
going to open the final voting for those
people but this is going to be released
on Friday on video and on audio and a
lot of other people who voted initially
are then going to be able to watch it
they will then vote over the next few
days and next Tuesday about a week from
today we're going to award the twisty
roll to the winner but that's just part
of the game meanwhile we did have a very
interesting clash of ideas I thank you
both and thanks for watching we will
certainly have more online debates like
these but I hope to see you all at our
physical space at the subculture theater
and then not-too-distant future
good evening
you